let's convert 138 over 27 into a mixed
number so this is essentially the same
thing as
138 divided by 27 and so we can divide
27
into 130
and let's see how many times let's see
27 is almost 30 so it's definitely gonna
go into it four times would it go into
it five times let's try it out let's try
out five
five times seven is thirty five 35 5
times 2 is 10 plus 3 is 13. or another
way to think about it 5 times 7 is 35 5
times 20 is 100 100 plus 35 is 135. and
it seems like we got it right if this
number was larger than 138 then that
means we shot too high here and if the
difference between 138 and this number
were larger than 27 then that means we
shot too low but here the difference
seems just right 138 minus 135 is 3
is 3. and if we wanted to convert this
right over here to a decimal we could
keep dividing we would divide 27 into 3.
but we just want to convert this into a
mixed number and we're essentially done
27 goes into 138 five times it goes into
it five times and and if we wanted to
keep dividing it it would be five and
three twenty sevens or another way of
thinking about it five times and there's
a remainder of three so we have three
twenty sevenths left over
three twenty sevenths three
twenty sevenths left over five and three
twenty sevenths another way that you
could rewrite this expression up here
instead of one thirty eight over twenty
seven you could rewrite it as 135
plus 3
plus 3
over 27
over
27. now this part right over here this
is equal to 135
over 27 plus 3 over 27
and this simplifies to 5. so 5 and 3 27
5 and 3 27.